>> GREG: WELCOME BACK.
SAM STILL RAISING HE WILL OUT BY
THE BAGGAGE CAROUSEL.
SO IS FOCUS ON DIVERSITY TO
BLAME FOR HIRING THE THIEF FROM
BAGGAGE CLAIM?
SAM, THE NONBINARY 35-YEAR-OLD
DEPUTY ASSISTANT SECRETARY FOR
SPENT FUEL AND WASTE AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF NUCLEAR ENERGY --
WE COULD HAVE RUN A MY PILLOW
COMMERCIAL IN BETWEEN SAYING
THAT JOB TITLE --
>> TRY MY SOCKS.
>> GREG: HE'S FACING NEW GRAND
LARCENY CHARGES AFTER ALLEGEDLY
STEALING A SUITCASE AT THE LAS
VEGAS AIRPORT.
IF MEMORY SERVES ME CORRECTLY,
WHICH IT RARELY DOES IT WAS JUST
LAST WEEK WHEN WE TOLD YOU SAM
WAS ON LEAVE FROM HER JOB FOR
SNATCHING ANOTHER WOMAN'S
LUGGAGE IN MINNEAPOLIS.
IN THAT INCIDENT SAM DENIED THE
THEFT AND LATER SAID IT WAS A
MISTAKE.
WE DIDN'T BUY IT.
>> BUT TYPICALLY THE CONTENTS
WILL LET YOU KNOW IF YOU GOT THE
WRONG BAG.
BUT IN SAM'S CASE HE CLAIMED THE
CLOTHES WERE HIS.
ALSO, HE NEVER CHECKED A BAG
BEFORE THE FLIGHT WHICH MAKES
WALKING OFF WITH A BAG MIGHTY
STRANGE.
SO TRUE, BRILLIANT MAN.
BRILLIANT TALL, GORGEOUS MAN.
ACCORDING TO THE LOCAL LAS VEGAS
NEWS, IT'S UNCLEAR WHEN THE NEW
CRIME OCCURRED, AND ALTHOUGH THE
BIDEN WHITE HOUSE SEEMED TO
FOREGO THE VETTING PROCESS DUE
TO SAM'S NONBRING THEIR
INTERSECTIONAL APPEAL EVEN
ALLIES IN THE GAY COMMUNITY ARE
ON TO THE ALLEGED CRIMINAL
SCAMS.
LGBTG NATION IS NOW QUESTIONING
WHETHER SAM'S OUTRAGEOUS STORY
WAS ALWAYS TOO GOOD TO BE TRUE
BUT IF YOU MISSED ALL THE RED
FLAGS WITH SAM I RECOMMEND YOU
NEVER TRY BULL FIGHTING.
HE PLANNED TO BE A CONVERSION
THERAPY SURVIVOR BUT THERE ARE
MORE HOLES IN THAT STORY THAN
SAM'S FISH NETS.
WRITES THE AUTHOR, RED FLAGS
REGARDING BRITTON WERE
OVERWHELMING AND OBVIOUS.
IS SAM A FAB UIST OR LEGITIMATE
SURVIVOR AFTER 12 YEARS?
I CAN'T DEFINITIVELY SAY.
BUT WE COULD DEFINITIVELY NOT
SAY DEFINITIVELY.
BUT WE CAN SAY FOR SURE THAT SAM
IS INTO KINKY PUPPY PLAY.
THAT'S WHEN YOU GET AROUSED BY
MAKING SOMEONE WEAR A LEATHER
DOG MASK AND WALKING THEM AROUND
ON A LEASH WHICH REMINDS ME,
TODD, WHAT ARE YOU DOING THIS
WEEKEND?
[LAUGHTER]
>> GREG: TODD, YOU KNOW WHAT
DRIVES ME CRAZY ABOUT THIS STORY
IS WE'RE SUPPOSED TO PRETEND
THAT WE DIDN'T NOTICE SOMETHING
WAS WRONG UNTIL HE WAS ARRESTED.
OH, MY GOODNESS, WHAT'S
HAPPENING?
NO, NO, NO, NO, NO.
>> MAYBE TRUMP WAS ON TO
SOMETHING WHEN HE SAID I LIKE
PEOPLE THAT LOOK LIKE CENTRAL
CASTING WHEN THEY GO FOR THE
JOB.
THIS ISN'T CENTRAL CASTING
UNLESS IT'S A WEIRD SHOW.
YOU HIT IT RIGHT ON THE HEAD
WHEN YOU SAID THIS IS BASICALLY,
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION USING
THEIR WOKE BINGO CARD TO APPOINT
PEOPLE.
THEY CONSISTENTLY HIRE
UNQUALIFIED INDIVIDUALS JUST SO
THEY CAN FILL OUT THAT WOKE
CARD, AND GREG, WE'RE LEFT
HOLDING THE BAG.
>> GREG: NICELY DONE.
[APPLAUSE]
>> THANK YOU.
>> JOE, THAT'S ALL YOURS IF YOU
WANT IT.
AND ONE FINAL POINT ON THIS, YOU
SAID IT IN THAT BEAUTIFUL CLIP
YOU SHOWED OF THAT AMAZING GUY.
WHAT SICK, DEPRAVED INDIVIDUAL
GOES TO FREAKEN BAGGAGE CLAIM IF
THEY HAVEN'T CHECKED A BAG?
YOU GET TO AVOID THAT
MONSTROSITY OF 20 MINUTES OF
WAITING AND STEPPING IN FRONT OF
THE LADY WHO TRIES TO STEAL YOUR
BAG BECAUSE SHE CAN'T SEE.
I'M SORRY, I'M FIRED UP.
>> GREG: YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT.
THE SECOND ONE, HE CAN'T SAY
IT'S A MISTAKE.
KAT: IT'S NOT HE, IT'S THEY.
I'M SORRY, DON'T USE GENDER.
JUST SAY THEY, THEM, THERE IS
PLENTY TO TALK ABOUT WITH THIS
PERSON.
>> IT TOOK ME AN HOUR TO GO
THROUGH THAT DARN ARTICLE.
WHO, THEY?
KAT: I'M HERE TO HELP YOU.
THEY IS A [ BLEEP ] MORON.
[APPLAUSE]
KAT: AGAIN, LAST TIME WE TALKED
ABOUT THIS, I SAID THIS.
YOU DON'T DO CRIMES.
YOU CERTAINLY DO CRIMES AT AN
AIRPORT WHERE EVERYONE IS
WATCHING YOU ON VIDEO BUT
APPARENTLY YOU'RE SO STUPID
YOU'RE DOING THIS MORE THAN
ONCE, AND THE DEFENSE IS LIKE I
DIDN'T KNOW IT WASN'T MY BAG.
YOU DID BECAUSE YOU TOOK THE
LABEL OFF AND PEOPLE SAW DO YOU
THAT, TOO.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT DEFENSE THERE
WOULD POSSIBLY BE.
OR MAKE IT ENVIRONMENTAL.
LISTEN, I'M A -- LOOK, I'M NOT
GOING TO SAY I'M A REDUCED,
REUSE, RECYCLE GUY LIKE TODD
WOULD, I WILL SAY I'M A REDUCED,
RECYCLE, THEY, AND WHAT I WAS
DOING WASN'T STEALING, IT WAS
JUST PRE-SCRIPTED REUSING.
>> GREG: I'M NOT GOING TO USE
THEY.
I'M IN THE JORDAN PETERSON
SCHOOL.
NO ONE COMPELS ME TO USE
PRONOUNCE.
[APPLAUSE]
>> BUT YOUR POINT ABOUT DOING IT
IN A VERY SURVEILLED ENVIRONMENT
HAS MORE TO DO WITH ENTITLEMENT.
WHO CARES IF ANYBODY SEES ME?
THAT'S WHAT IT'S ABOUT.
IF THEY SEE ME I'M SPECIAL.
IT DOESN'T MATTER.
THAT'S WHERE I THINK IT'S COMING
FROM.
I WANT TO ASK YOU, TYRUS, THIS
IS VERY -- SAM'S ASCENDANCE IS
VERY SIMILAR TO GRINER'S
RELEASE, RIGHT?
IT'S LIKE, IF I HAD TO APPLY FOR
A JOB AGAINST SAM BRYNTON I
WOULDN'T GET IT BECAUSE I DIDN'T
TAKE THE BOXES.
IF I WERE NA'SHAN SEAN PRISON
AND GRINER WAS UP FOR IT, I
WOULDN'T GET RELEASED BEFORE HER
BECAUSE THEY ALL TICK THE BOXES.
BOXES MATTER MORE THAN
CHARACTER.
>> MARTIN LUTHER KING SAID NOT
TO JUDGE MEN AND WOMEN, I'M SURE
HE MEANT "THEY" AND "THEMES"
TOO, NOT BY THE COLOR OF THEIR
SKIN BUT BY THE CONSENT OF THE
CHARACTER.
THAT WAS THE GOAL OF THE CIVIL
RIGHTS MOVEMENT.
REGARDLESS OF HOW YOU WHO YOU
SLEPT WITH, WHAT YOU THOUGHT, IF
YOU WERE A GOOD PERSON YOU WERE
ACCEPTED AND RESPECTED.
WE DON'T DO THAT ANYMORE.
WE'VE GONE THE POLAR OPPOSITE TO
WHERE, IF YOU CHECK ENOUGH
BOXES, THE CONTENT OF YOUR
CONTACT IS IRRELEVANT.
AND WHO DOES IT HURT?
IT HURTS THE GROUP YOU
REPRESENT.
>> GREG: OF COURSE.
>> SO THERE ARE QUALIFIED,
NONBINARY THEY AND THEM'S WHO
CAN DO THIS JOB.
MEN AND WOMEN WHO CAN DO THIS
JOB AT A HIGH LEVEL BUT THEY
AREN'T GETTING THAT OPPORTUNITY
BECAUSE THIS INDIVIDUAL LOOKED
THE PART.
LOOKED SO MUCH THE PART THAT THE
VIRTUE SIGNALING PROGRESSIVES
THAT GAVE HIM A JOB DIDN'T CARE.
THIS WASN'T THE FIRST TIME THIS
INDIVIDUAL STOLE THINGS.
IT'S AN ARROGANCE.
IT'S SUCH AN ARROGANCE TO WHERE
I WILL GO TAKE A BAG, AND RIP
THE NAME OFF OF IT, IN AN
AIRPORT, AND ROLL OUT OF IT AND
THIS IS NOT THE SECOND TIME.
THIS IS PROBABLY THE HUNDREDTH
TIME.
HE'S BEEN DOING THIS FOR A LONG
TIME, AND BECAUSE YOU CAN'T --
THEY, THEM, WHAT, IT, I'M A
CONSPIRACY THEORIST, MY
PRONOUNCE [ BLEEP ] I TOLD YOU
SO.
[APPLAUSE]
>> BUT IT ALL GOES BACK TO THE
SAME THING.
I DON'T CARE HOW THEY DRESS.
HOW THEY LOOK.
HE OR SHE LOOKS.
THE CHARACTER IS DISGUSTING.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
KAT: FOR ME I'LL CALL YOU
WHATEVER I WANT BUT IF YOU TALE
FROM ME I'LL BE CALLING THE
COPS.
>> GREG: JOE, I DON'T KNOW WHAT
PRONOUN YOU GO BY.
>> JOE: CALL ME THIS WEEKEND,
GREG.
[LAUGHTER]
>> NOW WHAT, GUTFELD!?
>> I TELL YOU WHAT, THIS GUY CAN
SPIN A YARN.
MAYBE THAT'S WHY JOE BIDEN HIRED
HIM BECAUSE IF YOU LISTEN TO JOE
BIDEN, HE'S A TRUCK DRIVER THAT
WAS RAISED BY PUERTO RICANS, AND
HE HAS OIL CANCER.
[LAUGHTER]
>> SO HE FITS RIGHT IN.
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE THE OTHER
APPLICANTS BEFORE I JUDGE.
MAYBE IT WAS LIKE SOME EXECUTIVE
AT ENRON, AND HUNTER BIDEN.
[LAUGHTER]
>> IF YOU DON'T WANT TO BE
VETTED, IF YOU DON'T WANT TO BE
VETTED BY A DEMOCRATIC
GOVERNMENT, NONBINARY,
DELIBERATELY UGLY YOURSELF,
TERRIBLE CHOICE IN LICK
STIPULATE.
YOU WON'T GET KINK SHAMED, OR
YOU CAN ACCUSE EVERY CRITIC OF
TRANSPHOBIA.
YOU'VE GOT IT MADE.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT CONFUSES ME?
WHEN A WOMAN IS OVERSEXUAL THEY
CALL HER ALL KINDS OF NAMES BUT
IF A MAN TRANSITIONS TO BE
WOMAN-ESK OR FEMININE AND IS
COMPLETELY LIKE THAT, THEY REFER
TO THEM AS A HERO.
>> WHO DOES THAT REMIND YOU OF?
THE CANADIAN TEACHER.
[LAUGHTER]
>> GREG: WE'LL DO AN ENTIRE HOUR
ON THA